stell thing in the bush she's still
thinking the bush she's walking through
the grass one day and all of a sudden I
saw her another player on a job today
face all day hello and welcome to
Playstation grenade before this one
begins a quick note that I had a couple
of technical issues I had a few issues
with the framerate so it goes from 30 to
60 frames so if it looks like it's
losing a few frames
I had technical issues on my side and I
couldn't get the frame rate correct and
the other problem was a crashing issue
which I played about 15 games and it
crashed seven times this was fixed by
the end of the beta so if this should be
reflected in the final game you know me
I don't like to concentrate on just
getting their frame enjoy it right where
should we go for our first ever drop
straight down Missy what's below us oh
oh okay maybe I'm jumping into things or
literally that looks like the asylum
from well I want to say world at war am
i right someone tell me in the comments
there's lots of people here right let's
do this come on any weapon will do
anything at all by the juice okay okay
bandages I'll be quick heals weapons
tactical I have no idea what fast
magazine means oh no it's one of those
games where you have to know about guns
I just know about shooting things hello
me
whoa boat sponge bullet sponge okay so
armor is a huge thing in this game got
it got it ready what's in your backpack
mate done what that is I'll take it
though just a sec can I hear zombies
they're zombies I hope it's really there
and not just some sort of sound file
look at his real zombies is PvE VP play
a versus environment player versus
player this should be good
wonder if there's anybody around there's
some right action going down let's get
involved
[Music]
so me ramana don't know hey yo get down
[Music]
so alright get ahead gonna get it to the
bottom left-hand corner that's my health
it's in numeric value rather than a bar
fifty nine health that's where it says
84 not great but it's okay what the heck
is this weapon circle others action is
actually round the front I can't aim to
top me whoa bullet sponge comm we're in
the circle we're all good three down I'm
coming for you Nigel that's because T
would say come on four kills first go
ever this is good oh it's addicting this
just looking through someone's back
someone's going to shoot my face off and
we're up to a hundred hundred and nine
health 134 he'll come on or something
150 lucky boss you're even more newbie
that I am so textures the textures of
grass aren't great it does feel like a
beta especially the framerate the frame
rate seems to fluctuate from around so
of thirty to fifty so not quite 60
frames a second year all person
yeah we're getting there now we'll get
it there slowly understanding this game
up to six kills in our first ever game
we're gonna win our first ever game take
everything you got what are you getting
your bag don't know what that is I'll
take that what's that yeah okay I'll
have that
so the different scopes and everything
yeah this is gonna take time to
understand so if you play call of duty
you'll already know all these weapons
whereas I don't and I have no idea which
weapon is worthwhile I don't even know
which weapon is correct for like medium
range encounters
that's how clueless I am what was the
last call of duty game you guys plays I
think mine was modern warfare 2 and it's
because I used to rage quit all the time
and I used to smash my desk I used to
punch the wall
I was quite an aggressive teenager and I
didn't understand being calm so I'm
really worried that I'll go back to old
habits and I will become a rage-filled
monster playing call of duty I managed
to get away from it a few years ago I
never really looked back I never played
ghosts I think I played or I looked at
the first black ops game but this is the
fourth one now
so I am a complete clueless [ __ ]
most people coming in people coming in I
see a vehicle in the distance as he
stopped
I can hear them stealth we're stealth
genius
Boop be advised further collapse
expected relocate to save some bullet
drop like the bullet drop is very
realistic spray and pray my dear spray
and pray I'm not in anything from that
distance Oh heard someone you can't hit
me run like a butterfly no that's not
right it sting like a butterfly run like
a wasp come on bro let's do this hmm I
gonna have to work on that bullet drop
let's have some cover and what I really
want to build a fort I've been playing
for tonight far too much whenever you're
ready dude you're going down you're
going to be my seventh victim haha stay
calm stay calm
this is the kind of thing that used to
make me rage quit oh it's fine
it's okay it's only a quick error we'll
just wait it out and hopefully it will
start moving at some point cuz we're
still waiting and still waiting six
hours later there we go 100% of what I
will report the problem fix your damn
game Bungie let's test these long-range
weapons oh thank you
ping Hey well pinky here we go oh let's
make it like a film from Hollywood bomb
explosions everywhere dude you gotta
keep running no you don't lay down or
you playin out have you not seen behind
enemy lines that's the first person I've
seen in this entire game show your head
oh oh oh
that's not really the reaction you want
is it
pokey damn head I got a grappling hook
what the hell I wore grenade run away
run away I'll just run away run away
with my suppressed sniper rifle now run
away run away come back another day
will does camping help I think it does
help you know it's in camp till the end
this is we're gonna get that win so
we'll just camp all the way
it's coming it's coming let's go it it's
coming you realized further collapse
expected relocate a safe so this is my
camping splice circle collapse imminent
get to safety get to buddy safety I like
your voice you sound like weird bummer
blackouts
I like the icon on the side so you know
how far away from the storm you are
that's damn good that's damn good
there's a sniper hill we'll go take
sniper Hill we're gonna camp to victory
from the snipers edge stay calm stay
calm that armor he's got is ridiculous
is that juggernaut juggernaut [ __ ] on
the juggernaut you hear me twice I'm
enjoying sitting in the mountains that
suits my play style to be completely
honest and if you spot people in the
distance oh it did which Bush did he go
in that one no that one no hmm that one
no this one yeah more people coming
where's my treat there's my tree this is
my tree there are many trees like it but
this is my true be advised further
collapse expected relocate a safe zone
relocate dawn or aren't darlin oh there
was no bullet drop on that one yeah this
is gonna take me days to figure out what
somebody needs somebody near coffee get
it
skills another one was that him rolling
down the hill
my aim is terrible I want a mouse and
keyboard come on dude 1v1 me bro
spray-and-pray come on be aggressive oh
oh is that what we're doing we're
throwing nades each other spine darling
what happens
I swore you get sitrep circle collapse
imminent get to safety run away run away
in the prime position like you gotyou
once go and poke your head come on there
he is just reload calm yourself down at
him calm yourself down line up the shot
whoa is that that side threw that one
away I the high ground goal Mellon more
ahead this win this bloody wind is
taking forever
come on Sarah
we gotta do death action action from the
top section let's get involved wine
shots extra points for the groin hit him
in the head just the wrong head there is
not a chance we are getting into this
safe zone we need a vehicle any vehicles
in here
no but there's some bullets vehicle
vehicle vehicle vehicle pick me up
Buster pick me up
so collapse yeah boy
thank you for bringing me this vehicle
you are my favorite uber uber drive
yourself don't mind if I do
wheels McGee
Oh mani feels like playing Borderlands
these controls
this is the loudest motorbike in the
history of motorbikes Medical Supply
Drop incoming now
move our bike in hey fellow motorbike Oh
crud what am I done I'm on the back ah
ah
don't run boss don't run boss we could
have been together I'll come say hello
anyway the cuddle
oh no he's absolutely pummeled the heck
out of me yeah there is still thing in
the bush she's still thing in the bush
she's walking through the grass one day
and all of a sudden I saw her another
play around jump in the face all day
bfi's further collapse expected relocate
to safe zone roger roger ten-4
okay dokay how do I get myself in these
stupid places
I'm not sure what happens with the storm
but I think we're going to find out very
soon
who's gonna hold their nerve mano that's
my role versus mano with mano it's just
next to me he's in the wall to the left
I will sneak up behind the first one in
charge at the second in this hope that
we have the hell for it together back in
I knows where I am this is all gone
wrong
got him once where's the other guy the
other guy in the head
[Music]
we're hi oh we're hi sitrep circle
collapse imminent get to safety
no I have to kill this man he's more
important than winning the game
time to do late he's behind the rock I
think just gotta hope this all the way
in should be hearing footsteps by now
yeah yeah he's behind the bush
yeah there is oh I missed every single
bullets
thanks aim assist flank I'm ready bro
get in Gary Nall died right top five
we've got five of them this is our game
confidence is everything here yes he is
full of bullets sitrep oh come off there
how many bullets two people taking this
game yes don't get vexed it don't get
vexed it's fine it's fine you're already
looking for an excuse to lose here
behind the bush
just this one guy to get we're going
short-range what we got we got a
grappler we've got a grappler and
short-range let's do this my ass off I
want to cry because of you
blackops Paul spine I'm like about
enough I really have had enough I can't
keep doing this every time I get to the
last two it crushes so I'm going to walk
away anyway thank you for watching I'm
sure this won't actually ever become a
video because I didn't win and I hate
not putting videos up when I don't win
but we'll see if this is a video thank
you for staying till the end I apologize
for my potty mouth it's been a pleasure
anyway I'll see you next time
you